TONIGHT."
HAPPY NEW YEAR, NEWLY
ELECTED UTAH SENATOR MITT
ROMNEY KICKED OFF 2019 WITH
AN OP-ED IN THE "THE
WASHINGTON POST" THAT
SAVAGED DONALD TRUMP'S
CHARACTER AND LEADERSHIP.
ROMNEY'S ATTACK AND TRUMP'S
RESPONSE THIS MORNING ON
TWITTER ARE THE LATEST
SALVOS IN THE LONG STANDING
PERSONAL FEUD BETWEEN THE
TWO MEN.
IT'S EVEN POSSIBLE THAT
ROMNEY IS PLANNING TO
CHALLENGE TRUMP FOR THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION IN
2020.
WE'LL SEE.
BUT, FOR NOW, ROMNEY'S PIECE
IS FASCINATING ON ITS OWN
TERMS.
AND WELL-WORTH READING.
IT'S A WINDOW HOW THE PEOPLE
IN CHARGE IN BOTH PARTIES
SEE OUR COUNTRY.
ROMNEY'S MAIN COMPLAINT IN
THE PIECE IS THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS A DIVISIVE LEADER.
THAT'S TRUE, OF COURSE.
BENEATH THE PERSONAL SLICE
ROMNEY HAS A POLICY CRITIQUE
OF TRUMP.
HE SEEMS GENERALLY ANGRY
THAT TRUMP MIGHT PULL TROOPS
OUT OF THE SYRIAN CIVIL WAR.
ROMNEY DOESN'T EXPLAIN HOW
STAYING IN SYRIA WOULD
BENEFIT AMERICA.
HE DOESN'T CONSIDER THAT A
RELEVANT QUESTION.
MORE POLICING IN THE MIDDLE
EAST IS ALWAYS BETTER.
WE KNOW THAT.
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON AGREES.
CORPORATE TAX CUTS ARE ALSO
POPULAR IN WASHINGTON AND
ROMNEY IS STRONGLY ON BOARD
WITH THOSE, TWO.
HIS PIECE THROW AS RARE
COMPLIMENT TO TRUMP FOR
CUTTING THE CORPORATE RATE A
YEAR AGO.
THAT'S NOT SURPRISING ROMNEY
SPENT THE BULK OF HIS
BUSINESS CAREER AT A FIRM
CALLED BAIN CAPITOL.
IT INVENTED WHAT IS A
FAMILIAR BUSINESS STRATEGY
TAKING OVER EXISTING COMPANY
SHORT PERT PERIOD OF TIME.
CUT COSTS BY CUTTING
EMPLOYEES, DEBT AND MOVE ON.
HE BECAME FANTASTICALLY RICH
WHILE DOING.
THIS MEANWHILE A REMARKABLE
NUMBER OF THE COMPANIES ARE
NOW BANKRUPT OR EXTINCT.
THIS IS THE PRIVATE HE CAN
AT THIS TIME MODEL A RULING
CLASS SEES NOTHING WRONG
WITH IT THAT'S HOW THEY RULE
THE COUNTRY.
MITT ROMNEY REFERS TO
UNWAVERING SUPPORT FOR A
FINANCED BASED ECONOMY AND
INTERNATIONAL FOREIGNIST
POLICY AS THE MAINSTREAM
REPUBLICAN VIEW.
IS HE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
FOR GENERATIONS REPUBLICANS
HAVE CONSIDERED IT THEIR
DUTY TO MAKE THE WORLD SAFE
FOR BANKING WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROSECUTING
EVER MORE FOREIGN WARS.
MODERN DEMOCRATS GENERALLY
SUPPORT THOSE GOALS
ENTHUSIASTICALLY.
THERE ARE SIGNS, HOWEVER
THAT MOST PEOPLE DO NOT
SUPPORT THIS AGENDA AND NOT
JUST HERE IN AMERICA.
IN COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD, FRANCE, BRAZIL,
SWEDEN, THE PHILIPPINES,
GERMANY, MANY OTHERS, VOTERS
SUDDENLY ARE BACKING
CANDIDATES AND IDEAS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNIMAGINABLE
JUST A DECADE AGO.
THESE ARE NOT ISOLATED
EVENTS.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING ARE
ENTIRE POPULATIONS REVOLTING
AGAINST LEADERS WHO REFUSE
TO IMPROVE THEIR LIVES.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAS BEEN
HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS.
DONALD TRUMP RODE A SURGE OF
POPULAR DISCONTENT ALL THE
WAY TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
DOES HE UNDERSTAND THE
POLITICAL REVOLUTION THAT HE
HARNESSED?
CAN HE REVERSE THE ECONOMIC
AND CULTURAL TRENDS THAT ARE
DESTROYING AMERICA?
THOSE ARE OPEN QUESTIONS.
THEY ARE LESS RELEVANT THAN
WE THINK.
AT SOME POINT DONALD TRUMP
WILL BE GONE.
THE REST OF US WILL BE GONE,
TOO.
THE COUNTRY WILL REMAIN.
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY WILL IT
BE THEN?
HOW DO WE WANT OUR
GRANDCHILDREN TO LIVE?
THOSE ARE THE ONLY QUESTIONS
THAT MATTER.
THE ANSWER TO THEM USED TO
BE OBVIOUS.
THE OVERRIDING FOR AMERICA
IS PROSPERITY.
MEANING CHEAPER CONSUMER
GOODS.
IS THAT STILL TRUE?
DOES ANYONE STILL BELIEVE
THAT CHEAPER iPHONES OR
MORE AMAZON DELIVERIES ARE
OF PLASTIC GARBAGE FROM
CHINA ARE GOING TO MAKE US
HAPPY?
THEY HAVEN'T SO FAR.
A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE
DROWNING IN STUFF.
YET DRUG ADDICTION AND
SUICIDE ARE DEPOPULATING
LARGE PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
ANYONE WHO THINKS THE HEALTH
OF A NATION CAN BE SUMMED UP
IN G.D.P. IS AN IDIOT.
THE GOAL FOR AMERICA IS BOTH
SIMPLER AND MORE ALLUSIVE
THAN MERE PROSPERITY.
IT'S HAPPINESS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF
INGREDIENTS IN BEING HAPPY.
DIGNITY, PURPOSE,
SELF-CONTROL, INDEPENDENCE,
ABOVE ALL DEEP RELATIONSHIPS
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
YOU WANT FOR YOUR CHILDREN.
THEY ARE WHAT OUR LEADERS
SHOULD WANT FOR US AND WOULD
WANT IF THEY CARED.
BUT OUR LEADERS DON'T CARE.
WE HAVE RULED BY MERCENARIES
WHO FEEL NO LONG-TERM
OBLIGATION TO THE PEOPLE
THEY RULE.
THEY ARE DAY TRADERS.
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS.
THEY ARE JUST PASSING
THROUGH.
THEY HAVE NO SKIN IN THIS
GAME AND IT SHOWS.
THEY CAN'T SOLVE OUR
PROBLEMS.
THEY DON'T EVEN BOTHER TO
UNDERSTAND OUR PROBLEMS.
ONE THE BIGGEST LIES OUR
LEADERS TELL US IS THAT YOU
CAN SEPARATE ECONOMICS FROM
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
MATTERS.
ECONOMICS IS A TOPIC FOR
PUBLIC DEBATE.
FAMILY, PERSONAL MATTERS.
BOTH PARTIES BELIEVE THIS.
MEMBERS OF OUR EDUCATED YOU
WERE
UPRE
UPPER MIDDLE CLASS USUALLY
SUBSCRIBE THEM AS AS
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AND
SOCIALLY MODERATE.
FUNCTIONALLY LIBERTARIAN.
THEY DON'T CARE HOW YOU LIVE
AS LONG AS THE BILLS ARE
PAID AND THE MARKETS
FUNCTION.
SOMEHOW THEY DON'T SEE A
CONNECTION BETWEEN PEOPLE'S
PERSONAL LIVES AND THE
HEALTH OF OUR ECONOMY OR FOR
THAT MATTER THE COUNTRY'S
ABILITY TO PAY ITS BILLS.
AS FAR AS THEY ARE
CONCERNED, THESE ARE TWO
TOTALLY SEPARATE CATEGORIES.
SOCIAL CONSERVATIVES,
MEANWHILE, COME TO THE
DEBATE FROM THE OPPOSITE
PERSPECTIVE.
AND, YET REACH A STRIKINGLY
SIMILAR CONCLUSION.
THE REAL PROBABLE YOU WILL
HEAR THEM SAY IS THAT THE
AMERICAN FAMILY IS
COLLAPSING.
NOTHING CAN BE FIXED BEFORE
WE FIX THAT.
LIKE THE LIBERTARIANS THEY
CLAIM TO OPPOSE, MANY SOCIAL
CONSERVATIVES ALSO CONSIDER
MARKETS SACROSANCT.
THE IDEA THAT FAMILIES ARE
BEING CRUSHED BY MARKET
FORCES NEVER SEEMS TO OCCUR
TO THEM.
THEY REFUSE TO CONSIDER IT
CONSIDERING MARKETS SEEMS
LIKE HYPOCRISY.
BOTH SIDES OF THIS MISS THE
OBVIOUS POINTS.
CULTURE AND ECONOMICS ARE
INSEPARATABLY INTERTWINED
CERTAIN ECONOMIC SYSTEMS
ALLOW FAMILIES TO THRIVE.
THRIVING FAMILIES MAKE
ECONOMIES POSSIBLE.
YOU CAN'T SEPARATE THE TWO.
IT USED TO BE POSSIBLE TO
DENY THIS BUT IT'S NOT
ANYMORE.
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE NOW
OVERWHELMING.
HOW DO WE KNOW?
CONSIDER THE INNER CITIES,
30 YEARS AGO CONSERVATIVES
LOOKED AT DETROIT AND NEW
YORK AND MANY OTHER PLACES
AND HORRIFIED BY WHAT THEY
SAW CONVENTIONAL FAMILIES
HAD ALL ABOUT DISAPPEARED IN
POOR NEIGHBORHOODS.
MAJORITY OF CHILDREN BORN
OUT OF WEDLOCK.
SINGLE MOTHERS WERE THE
RULE.
CRIME AND DRUGS AND DISORDER
BECAME UNIVERSAL.
WHAT CAUSED THIS NIGHTMARE?
LIBERALS DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE QUESTION.
THEY WERE BENEFITING FROM
THE DISASTER IN THE FORM OF
RELIABLE VOTES CONSERVATIVES
THOUGH HAD AN EXPLANATION
FOR INNER CITY DYSFUNCTION
AND IT MADE SENSE.
BIG GOVERNMENT.
DECADES OF BADLY DESIGNED
SOCIAL PROGRAMS HAD DRIVEN
FATHERS FROM THE HOME AND
CREATED WHAT CONSERVATIVES
CALLED A CULTURE OF POVERTY
TO TRAP PEOPLE IN
GENERATIONAL DECLINE.
WELL, THERE WAS TRUTH IN
THIS.
BUT IT WASN'T THE WHOLE
STORY.
HOW DO WE KNOW?
WELL, BECAUSE VIRTUALLY THE
SAME THING HAS HAPPENED
DECADES LATER TO ANNUAL
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
POPULATION.
IN MANY WAYS RURAL AMERICA
NOW LOOKS LIKE DETROIT.
THIS IS STRIKING BECAUSE
RURAL AMERICANS WOULDN'T
SEEM TO HAVE VERY MUCH IN
COMMON WITH ANYONE FROM THE
INNER CITY.
THE GROUPS HAVE DIFFERENT
CULTURES, DIFFERENT THAT
DILINGSES, DIFFERENT
POLITICAL BELIEFS.
USUALLY THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
SKIN COLORS.
RURAL PEOPLE ARE WHITE
CONSERVATIVES, MOSTLY.
YET THE PATHOLOGIES OF
MODERN RURAL AMERICA ARE
FAMILIAR TO ANYONE WHO
VISITED DOWNTOWN BALTIMORE
IN THE 180S, STUNNING
OUT-OF-WEDLOCK BIRTH RATES,
HIGH MALE UNEMPLOYMENT.
A TERRIFYING DRUG EPIDEMIC.
TWO DIFFERENT WORLDS,
SIMILAR OUTCOMES.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
YOU THINK OUR RULING CLASS
WOULD BE DEEPLY INTERESTED
IN KNOWING THE ANSWER, BUT
MOSTLY THEY ARE NOT.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
INTERESTED.
IT'S EASIER TO IMPORT
FOREIGN LABOR TO TAKE THE
PLACE OF NATIVE BORN
AMERICANS WHO ARE SLIPPING
BEHIND.
NOW REPUBLICANS NOW
REPRESENT RURAL VOTERS.
THEY OUGHT TO BE INTERESTED.
HERE'S A BIG PART OF THE
ANSWER.
MALE WAGES DECLINE.
MANUFACTURING AND MALE
DOMINATED INDUSTRY ALL BUT
DISAPPEARED OVER THE COURSE
OF A GENERATION.
ALL THAT REMAINED IN MANY
PLACES WERE THE SCHOOLS AND
THE HOSPITALS AND BOTH OF
THEM ARE TRADITIONAL
EMPLOYERS OF WOMEN IN MANY
AREAS WOMEN SUDDENLINELY
MADE MORE THAN MEN.
BEFORE YOU APPLAUD THAT AS A
VICTORY FOR FEMINISM
CONSIDER THE EFFECTS.
STUDY AFTER STUDY SHOW WHEN
MEN MAKE LESS THAN WOMEN
THEY DON'T WANT TO MARRY
THEM.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD BUT THEY
DON'T.
OVER BIG POPULATIONS THIS
CAUSES A BIG DROP IN
MARRIAGE.
SPIKE IN OUT-OF-WEDLOCK
BIRTHS AND ALL THE DISASTERS
THAT INEVITABLY FOLLOW.
MORE ALCOHOL AND DRUG ABUSE.
FEWER FAMILIES FORMED IN THE
NEXT GENERATION.
THIS IS NOT SPECULATION OR
PROPAGANDA FROM
EVANGELICALS.
IT'S SOCIAL SCIENCE.
WE KNOW IT'S TRUE.
RICH PEOPLE KNOW IT BEST OF
ALL.
THAT'S WHY THEY GET MARRIED
BEFORE THEY HAVE KIDS.
THAT MODEL WORKS.
INCREASINGLY MARRIAGE IS A
LUXURY ONLY THE AFFLUENT IN
AMERICA CAN AFFORD.
AND, YET, AND HERE IS THE
BEWILDERING AND INFURIATING
PART.
THOSE VERY SAME AFFLUENT
MARRIED PEOPLE THE ONES WHO
MAKE VIRTUALLY ALL THE
DECISIONS IN OUR SOCIETY ARE
DOING PRETTY MUCH NOTHING TO
HELP THE PEOPLE BELOW THEM
TO HELP AND STAY MARRIED.
RICH PEOPLE ARE HAPPY TO
FIGHT MALARIA IN CONGO BUT
WORKING TO RAISE MEN'S WAGES
IN DAYTON OR DETROIT THAT'S
CRAZY.
THIS IS NEGLIGENCE ON A
MASSIVE SCALE.
BOTH PARTIES IGNORE THE
CRISIS IN MARRIAGE.
OUR MINDLESS CULTURAL
LEADERS ACT LIKE IT'S STILL
1961 AND THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
AMERICAN FAMILIES FACE IS
THAT SEXISM IS PREVENTING
MILLIONS OF HOUSEWIVES FROM
BECOMING INVESTMENT BANKERS
OR FACEBOOK EXECUTIVES.
FOR OUR RULING CLASS, MORE
INVESTMENT BANKING IS ALMOST
ALWAYS THE ANSWER.
THEY TEACH US IT'S MORE
VIRTUOUS TO DEVOTE YOUR LIFE
TO SOME SOULLESS CORPORATION
THAN IT IS TO RAISE YOUR OWN
KIDS.
SHERYL SANDBERG OF FACEBOOK
WROTE AN ENTIRE BOOK ABOUT
THIS.
SANDBERG EXPLAINED OUR FIRST
DUTY IS TO SHAREHOLDERS
ABOVE OUR OWN CHILDREN.
NO SURPRISE THERE.
SANDBERG HERSELF IS ONE OF
AMERICA'S BIGGEST
SHAREHOLDERS.
>> PROPAGANDA LIKE THIS HAS
MADE HER RICH.
WHAT'S REMARKABLE IS HOW THE
REST OF US RESPONDED TO IT.
WE DIDN'T QUESTION WHY
SANDBERG WAS SAYING.
THIS WE DIDN'T LAUGH IN HER
FACE AT THE PURE ABSURDITY
OF IT OUR CORPORATE MEDIA
CELEBRATED SANDBERG AS THE
LEADER OF A LIBERATION
MOVEMENT.
BOOK BECAME A BEST SELLER
"LEAN IN" AS IF PUTTING A
CORPORATION FIRST IS
EMPOWERMENT IT IS NOT IT IS
BONDAGE.
REPUBLICANS SHOULD SAY SO.
THEY ALSO SHOULD SPEAK OUT
AGAINST OUR FINANCIAL SYSTEM
NOT ALL COMMERCE IS GOOD.
WHY IS IT DEFENSIBLE TO LOAN
PEOPLE MONEY THEY CAN'T
POSSIBLY REPAY?
OR CHARGE THEM INTEREST THAT
IMPOVERISHES THEM.
PAYDAY LOAN OUTLETS IN POOR
NEIGHBORHOODS COLLECT
400 PERCENT ANNUAL INTEREST.
ARE WE OKAY WITH THAT?
WE SHOULD NOT BE.
LIBERTARIANS TELL US THAT'S
HOW MARKETS WORK CONSENTING
ADULTS MAKING VOLUNTARY
DECISIONS HOW TO LIVE THEIR
LIVES.
OKAY, BUT IT'S ALSO
DISGUSTING.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT AMERICA
YOU OUGHT TO OWE POISE THE
EXPLOITATION OF AMERICANS
WHETHER IT'S HAPPENING IN
THE INNER CITY OR WALL
STREET.
BY THE WAY IF YOU REALLY
LOVED YOUR FELLOW AMERICANS
AS OUR LEADERS SHOULD, IT
WOULD BREAK YOUR HEART TO
SEE THEM HIGH ALL THE TIME,
WHICH THEY ARE.
A HUGE NUMBER OF OUR KIDS,
ESPECIALLY OUR BOYS ARE
SMOKING WEED CONSTANTLY.
YOU MAY NOT REALIZE THAT
BECAUSE NEW TECHNOLOGY HAS
MADE IT ALL BUT ODORLESS,
BUT IT'S EVERYWHERE.
THAT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT.
ONCE OUR LEADERS UNDERSTOOD
THEY COULD GET RICH FROM
MAIN, MAIN
MARI, MAIN
MARIJUMAIN
MARIJUANIN
MARIJUANAN
MARIJUANA BECAME UBIQUITOUS.
MANY PLACES LEGALIZED OR
DECRIMINALIZED IT SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE JOHN BOEHNER NOW
LOBBIES FOR THE MARIJUANA
INDUSTRY.
FELLOW REPUBLICANS.
BETTER THAN ALCOHOL, THEY
TELL US.
MAYBE, WHO CARES?
TALK ABOUT MISSING THE
POINT.
TRY HAVING DINNER WITH A
19-YEAR-OLD WHO HAS BEEN
SMOKING WEED IN THE LIFE IS
GONE.
PASSIVE, FLAT, TRAPPED IN
THEIR OWN HEADS.
DO YOU WANT THAT FOR YOUR
KIDS.
OF COURSE NOT.
THEN WHY ARE OUR LEADERS
PUSHING IT ON US?
YOU KNOW THE REASON.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT US.
WHEN YOU CARE ABOUT PEOPLE,
YOU DO YOUR BEST TO TREAT
THEM FAIRLY.
OUR LEADERS DON'T EVEN TRY.
THEY HAND OUT JOBS AND
CONTRACTS AND SCHOLARSHIPS
AND SLOTS TO PRESTIGIOUS
UNIVERSITIES BASED PURELY ON
HOW WE LOOK.
THERE IS NOTHING LESS FAIR
THAN THAT THOUGH OUR TAX
CODE DOES COME CLOSE.
UNDER OUR CURRENT SYSTEM AN
AMERICAN WORKS HO WORKS FOR
SALARY PAYS TWICE THE TAX
RATE AS SOMEBODY LIVING OFF
INHERITED.
HALF THE RATE WE TAX LABOR.
SWEET DEAL IF YOU WORK IN
FINANCE AS MANY OF OUR
RICHEST PEOPLE DO.
IN 2010, FOR EXAMPLE, MITT
ROMNEY MADE ABOUT
$22 MILLION IN INVESTMENT
INCOME.
HE PAID AN EFFECTIVE FEDERAL
TAX RATE OF 14%.
FOR NORMAL UPPER MIDDLE
CLASS WAGE OWNERRERS THE TAX
RATE IS NEARLY 40%.
NO WONDER MITT ROMNEY
SUPPORTS THE STATUS QUO.
BUT, FOR EVERYONE ELSE, IT'S
INFURIATING.
OUR LEADERS RARELY MENTION
ANY OF THIS.
OUR MULTITIERED TAX CODE IS
BASED ON FREE MARKET.
PLEASE, IT'S BASED ON LAWS
THAT THE CONGRESS PASSED.
LAWS THAT COMPANIES LOBBIED
FOR IN ORDER TO INCREASE
THEIR ECONOMIC ADVANTAGE.
IT WORKED WELL FOR THOSE
PEOPLE, THEY DID INCREASE
THEIR ECONOMIC ADVANTAGE.
FOR EVERYONE ELSE THERE WAS
A BIG COST.
UNFAIRNESS IS PROFOUNDLY
DECISIVE.
WHEN YOU FAVOR ONE CHILD
OVER ANOTHER, YOUR KIDS
DON'T HATE YOU, THEY HATE
EACH OTHER.
THAT HAPPENS IN COUNTRIES,
TOO.
IT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTRY.
PROBABLY BY DESIGN.
DIVIDED COUNTRIES ARE EASIER
TO RULE.
NOTHING DIVIDES US THAN THE
PERCEPTION SOME PEOPLE ARE
GETTING SPECIAL TREATMENT.
IN OUR COUNTRY SOME PEOPLE
DEFINITELY ARE GETTING
SPECIAL TREATMENT.
REPUBLICANS SHOULD OPPOSE
THAT WITH EVERYTHING THAT
THEY HAVE.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHAT KIND
OF COUNTRY DO YOU WANT TO
LIVE IN?
WELL, A FAIR COUNTRY, A
DECENT COUNTRY.
A COHESIVE COUNTRY.
A COUNTRY WHOSE LEADERS
DON'T ACCELERATE THE FORCES
OF CHANGE PURELY FOR THEIR
OWN PROFIT AND AMUSEMENT.
A COUNTRY YOU MIGHT
RECOGNIZE WHEN YOU'RE OLD.
A COUNTRY THAT LISTENS TO
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIVE
IN BROOKLYN.
A COUNTRY WHERE YOU CAN MAKE
A SOLID LIVING OUTSIDE OF
THE BIG CITIES A COUNTRY
WHERE LEWISTON, MAINE, SEEMS
ALMOST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
WEST SIDE OF LOS ANGELES.
A COUNTRY WHERE
ENVIRONMENTALISM MEANS
GETTING OUTSIDE AND PICKING
UP THE TRASH.
A CLEAN, ORDERLY STABLE
COUNTRY THAT RESPECTS ITSELF
AND ABOVE ALL A COUNTRY
WHERE NORMAL PEOPLE WHO GREW
UP NO PLACE SPECIAL CAN GET
MARRIED AND HAVE HEACH KIDS
AND REPEAT UNTO THE
GENERATIONS.
A COUNTRY THAT ACTUALLY
CARES ABOUT FAMILIES,
BUILDING BLOCK OF
EVERYTHING.
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO GET A
COUNTRY LIKE THAT?
LEADERS WHO WANT IT.
FOR NOW THOSE LEADERS WILL
HAVE TO BE REPUBLICANS,
THERE'S NO OPTION AT THIS
POINT.
BUT, FIRST, REPUBLICAN
LEADERS WILL HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MARKET
CAPITALISM IS NOT A
RELIGION.
MARKET CAPITALISM IS A TOOL,
LIKE A STAPLE GUN OR A
TOASTER.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A FOOL
TO WORSHIP IT OUR SYSTEM WAS
CREATED BY HUMAN BEINGS FOR
THE BENEFIT OF HUMAN BEINGS.
WE DO NOT EXIST TO SERVE
MARKETS.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
ANY ECONOMIC SYSTEM THAT
WEAKENS AND DESTROYS
FAMILIES IS NOT WORTH
HAVING.
A SYSTEM LIKE THAT IS THE
ENEMY OF A HEALTHY SOCIETY.
INTERNALIZING ALL OF THIS
WILL NOT BE EASY FOR
REPUBLICAN LEADERS.
THEY HAVE TOWN LEARN DECADES
OF BUMPER STICKER TALKING
POINTS AND CORPORATE
PROPAGANDA:  THEY WILL
LIKELY LOSE DONORS IN THE
PROCESS.
THEY WILL BE CRITICIZED.
LIBERTARIANS ARE CERTAINLY
TO CALL ANY DEVIATION FROM
MARKET A FORM OF SOCIALISM.
THAT'S A LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT SOCIALISM IS A
DISASTER.
IT DOES NOT WORK.
IN FACT, IT'S WHAT WE SHOULD
BE WORKING DESPROFITLY TO
AVOID.
BUT SOCIALISM IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO GET AND
VERY SOON UNLESS A GROUP OF
RESPONSIBLE PEOPLE IN OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEM REFORMS THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS NORMAL PEOPLE.